foreign
[Music]
[Music]
do not do to others what you do not want
done to yourself
real knowledge is to know the extent of
one's ignorance
he who speaks without modesty will find
it difficult to make his words good
[Music]
I hear and I forget I see and I remember
I do and I understand
everything has Beauty but not everyone
sees it
foreign
do not be ashamed of mistakes and thus
make them crimes
[Music]
isn't it a pleasure to study and
practice what you have learned
[Music]
it is not possible for one to teach
others what he cannot teach his own
family
[Music]
education breeds confidence confidence
breeds hope
hope breeds peace
[Music]
without feelings of respect what is
there to distinguish men from Beasts
[Music]
he who excels in study can follow an
official career
foreign
[Music]
s never forget kindnesses
we should feel sorrow but not sink under
its oppression
recompense injury with Justice
recompense kindness with kindness
foreign
[Music]
diamond with a flaw than a pebble
without one
to love a thing means wanting it to live
[Music]
to go beyond is as wrong as to fall
short
[Music]
in a country well-governed poverty is
something to be ashamed of
things that are done it is needless to
speak about things that are past it is
needless to blame
[Music]
looking at small advantages prevents
great affairs from being accomplished
people may be made to follow a path of
action but they may not be made to
understand it
foreign
s do not fear to abandon them
[Music]
the cautious seldom air
[Music]
men's Natures are alike it is their
habits that carry them far apart
it is only the wisest and the stupidest
that cannot change
[Music]
the object of the superior man is truth
the essence of knowledge is having it to
apply it not having it to confess your
ignorance
[Music]
a man who does not plan ahead will find
trouble at his door
[Music]
humility is the solid foundation of all
virtues
when anger arises think of the
consequences
study the past if you would Define the
future
[Music]
to be wronged is nothing unless you
continue to remember it
The Scholar who cherishes the love of
comfort is not fit to be deemed a
scholar
wheresoever you go go with all your
heart
[Music]
the real fault is to have faults and not
amend them
[Music]
when we see men of a contrary character
we should turn inwards and examine
ourselves
[Music]
a fool despises Good Counsel but a wise
man takes it to heart
he who will not economize will have to
agonize
foreign
that I am not known I seek to be worthy
to be known
without an acquaintance with the rules
of propriety it is impossible for
character to be established
mankind differs from the animals only by
little and most people throw that away
[Music]
to see what is right and not to do it is
want of courage or a principle
it is better to light one small candle
than to curse the darkness
[Music]
respect yourself and others will respect
you
[Music]
when Prosperity comes do not use all of
it
ignorance is the night of the mind but a
night without moon or star
[Music]
they must stop and change who would be
constant in happiness or wisdom
foreign
man meditates upon good thoughts the
better will be his world and the World
At Large
[Music]
we take great pains to persuade others
that we are happy then in endeavoring to
think so ourselves
[Music]
if a man takes no thought about what is
distant he will find sorrow near at hand
foreign
toward everyone as if receiving a great
guest
[Music]
what the superior man seeks is in
himself what the small man seeks is in
others
[Music]
the strength of a Nation derives from
the Integrity of the home
when you see a worthy person Endeavor to
emulate him when you see an unworthy
person examine your inner self
[Music]
wealth and rank are what people desire
but unless they be obtained in the right
way they may not be possessed
[Music]
The Wheel of Fortune turns round
incessantly who can say to himself today
I shall be Uppermost
foreign
the father who does not teach his son
his duties is equally guilty with the
son who neglects them
[Music]
the parents age must be remembered both
for joy and anxiety
[Music]
when I walk along with two others from
at least one I will be able to learn
[Music]
your own heart you find nothing wrong
there what is there to fear
[Music]
foreign
study the past if you would Divine the
future
[Music]
virtue is not left to stand alone he who
practices it will have neighbors
[Music]
nobody's so small that you may commit it
and no virtue is so small that you may
Overlook it
[Music]
not worry about whole holding High
position rather worry about playing your
proper role
[Music]
not impose on others what you yourself
do not desire
[Music]
acquire new knowledge whilst thinking
over old and you may become a teacher of
others
[Music]
sincerity and Truth are the basis of
every virtue
[Music]
reviewing the old and deducing the new
makes a teacher
act with kindness and do not expect
gratitude
worry not that no one knows of you
seek to be worth knowing
[Music]
he who conquers himself is the mightiest
Warrior
[Music]
ability will never catch up with the
demand for it
[Music]
to see and listen to The Wicked is
already the beginning of wickedness
[Music]
before you embark on a journey of
Revenge dig two graves
[Music]
a youth is to be regarded with respect
how do you know that his future will not
be equal to your present
your mind on Truth hold firm to Virtue
rely on loving kindness and find your
recreation in the Arts
[Music]
boldness without the rules of propriety
becomes insubordination
[Music]
fine words and insinuating appearance
are seldom associated with true virtue
[Music]
learn as though you would never be able
to master hold as though you would be in
fear of losing
[Music]
I am not one who was born in the
possession of knowledge I am one who is
fond of antiquity and Earnest in seeking
it there
when you know a thing to hold that you
know it and when you do not know a thing
to allow that you do not know it
this is knowledge
The Faults of a superior person are like
the Sun and Moon
they have their faults and everyone sees
them they change and everyone looks up
to them
when a man's knowledge is sufficient to
attain
and his virtue is not sufficient to
enable him to hold whatever he may have
gained he will
there is no right amount of sex and
giving up sex for a long time shouldn't
have negative side effects
to be able under all circumstances to
practice five things constitutes perfect
virtue these five things are gravity
generosity of Soul sincerity earnestness
and kindness
[Music]
do not be desirous of having things done
quickly do not look at small advantages
desire to have things done quickly
prevents their being done thoroughly
foreign
the will to win the desire to succeed
the urge to reach your full potential
these are the keys that will unlock the
door to personal excellence
[Music]
he with whom neither slander that
gradually soaks into the Mind nor
statements that startled like a wound in
the flesh is successful and may be
called intelligent indeed
thank you
[Music]
there are three things to be aware of
through life when a man is Young let him
beware of his appetites when he is
middle-aged of his Passions
when old of covetousness
[Music]
virtue is more to man than either water
or fire
I have seen men die from treading on
water and fire
but I have never seen a man die from
treading the course of virtue
[Music]
if I am walking with two other men each
of them will serve as my teacher I will
pick out the good points of the one and
imitate them and the bad points of the
other and correct them in myself
to put the world in order we must first
put the nation in order to put the
nation in order we must first put the
family in order
to put the family in order we must
cultivate our personal life
and to cultivate our personal life we
must first set our hearts right
[Music]
isn't it also great when friends visit
from distant places
if one Remains Not annoyed when he is
not understood by people around him is
he not a sage
[Music]
foreign
with coarse rice to eat with water to
drink and my bended arm for a pillow
I still have joy in the midst of these
things
riches and honors acquired by
unrighteousness are to me as a floating
cloud
[Music]